the white house is pushing back on
reports the trump administration
turned down an opportunity to buy
millions of extra vaccine doses from
pfizer over the summer the new york
times reports officials made a decision
that could have allowed
other countries to lock in contracts on
the limited supply
wii xi zhang is at the white house wija
what do we know
good morning anthony senior
administration officials are denying the
reports and said they are absolutely
confident
that there will be enough doses to
vaccinate the american people
before the middle of next year in july
the u.s government
signed a contract with the american
company pfizer
locking in 100 million doses of the
vaccine enough for 50 million people
but there are reports it had the option
to buy much more than that
in a statement pfizer said any
additional doses beyond the 100 million
are subject to a separate
and mutually acceptable agreement the
company is not able to comment on any
confidential discussions with the u.s
government
today president trump is expected to
sign an executive order to prioritize
american citizens for the doses of
vaccine that are procured by the
administration
before they are given to other countries
though it's unclear what power
that order will have mr trump plans to
sign that order at a three-hour long
vaccine summit here at the white house
that will focus on distributing the
vaccine
moderna and pfizer were invited but they
are not coming
and the white house did not invite
anyone from the incoming biden
administration saying the event will be
live streamed so everyone can watch it
tony all right thank you very much